si c'est quand même incroyable
des objets aussi beau tous les gens
devra les acheter pour les maîtres chez
eux les personnes
personne personne
leonard leo n'a rêvé toi il faut que
j'en parle
parce que ça si les confier aux fins non
non non non il n'ya pas le feu mais il
faut que je te parle à
voudrais-tu l'appétit ce que tu viens de
dire avec plaisir léonard il faut que je
te parle
c'est bien ce que j'avais compris
mais c'est quand même incroyable enfin
tu entendu il faut que je te parle et on
a aussi les personnages
mais ce renard commence à m'énerver
écoute si tu ne sors pas immédiatement
c'est moi qui descendante à mal
l'accord d'un corps 15 émir tu as gagné
j'abandonne de toute façon ma sieste est
gâché allez je t'écoute voilà personne
ne veut acheter mais cocottes en papier
c'est normal
comment c'est normal ils sont elles sont
très belles je les ai colorier moi même
enfin bête je ne suis pas malade j'ai
même exprès choisi un papier très solide
ça n'est pas possible d'être aussi belle
romance pourquoi dit sans arrêt que je
suis bête parce que tu es belle voire à
moi ce n'est pas une réponse l'ue
réfléchit casimir tu as oublié
l'essentiel non elles sont très réussis
et je n'ai rien oublié c'est d'un
prévenir les habitants de l'île que tu
avais des cocottes en papier à vendre
non mais tu as raison s'ils ne le savent
pas ils ne viendront pas au creusot semi
ben tiens tu vois pas non non moi j'ai
le droit de le dire à mes patois
alors que faut-il faire
tiens tu dois faire de la publicité ah
bon c'est plus joli conte les cocottes
en papier mais non ça n'a rien à voir la
publicité c'est la façon de faire
connaître le produit que tu veux vendre
pour que les gens sachent qu'il existe
alors il suffit que je parcours lille en
criant acheter mais cocottes en papier
achetés mais cocottes en papier peint
c'est sans aucun doute une très bonne
méthode
seulement je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
les fabriquer les vendre et parcourir
l'île en criant alors en gage d'un mais
ne compte pas sur moi je n'ai pas fini
ma sieste
contes africains
histoire de ligny francs et du compte
un jour line et faons prédire mois de la
forêt une à plusieurs rois d'enfants
rencontre le conte inuit
je parie la moitié de mon royaume que tu
n'es pas capable de manger aussi
longtemps que moi
le coq très fiers relève le défi
il accepte le pari ils se mettent tous
deux à manger au bout d'un moment
l'éléphant rassasié s'endort
la défense andorre
mais lorsqu'elle se réveille il trouve
le camp tu piques auront toujours des
grès sur le sol
sera met donc à manger l'éléphant puis
se rendort
m'épuiser
voilà tout d'un coup qu'il est réveillé
par de petits picotements sur son dos
elle était petite et elle avait été
payée qu'est-ce qui me pique là aussi
fort qui défend barack obama lakers et
moi dit le kop je mange tous les petits
à celle que tu as sur le dos
l'éléphant honteux s'aperçoit qu'il a
perdu son pari
vous voyez que ce n'est pas toujours les
plus ruraux qui ont le plus de
résistance
cette histoire me rappelle un certain
monstres préhistoriques qui se vante de
pouvoir manger des tonnes de
gloubiboulga
vous voyez qui je veux dire pointe à
l'agréable
tu as l'air de mauvaise humeur tout à
rien ne va plus y'a plus de saison
pourquoi dis-tu ça qui fait toujours
mauvais enfin qu'il fasse mauvais ne
suffit pas pour dire qu'il n'ya plus de
saisons il y en a toujours quatre
printemps été automne hiver mais c'est
une façon de parler une façon de parler
qui ne veut rien dire alors pourquoi
parler pour ne rien dire tout le monde
parle comme tout le monde parle pour ne
rien dire comment veux tu parlais pas
normalement mais surtout pour dire
quelque chose d'intelligent mais à quoi
veut tu admires à me reprendre sans
arrêt comme ça mais n'y a rien je
cherche tout simplement à t'apprendre ne
pas employer un mot pour un autre et à
ne pas dire n'importe quoi
je n'ai rien à apprendre de trois petits
magiciens à la nommant
à la noix c'est une au moins est ce que
veut dire l'expression à la noix
évidemment je t'écoute bon ça veut dire
à la gomme
ça veut dire deux rien du tout oui tu
n'es qu'un petit magicien de rien du
tout la donne rien du tout moi bien dit
à l'ats mois oui bon bah tu vas voir tu
auras la loi
attention un e-mail imany tous types de
strapping jnx nappes et hop
je te transformer en droit de coco et
même en notre concours qui parle c'est
de la magie de rien du tout ça
[Rires]
messahel et sur ton ou ta tête et c'est
même une belle tête de noaa tu vois que
tu ne sais pas ce que tu dis
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il je n'ai pas là
bonjour on a su dès ce 9 pardonnez moi
mon cher ami je suis ici aussi
aujourd'hui j'avais une grande nouvelle
annonce est mademoiselle julie et et à
moi vous ne voulez rien dire c'est à
dire que ça des ponts
est-ce que vous avez du temps libre oh
non non monsieur disney vous savez je
consacrais tout mon temps aux enfants à
la vente de mes ballons à mes chères
études
je suis très occupé si c'est à dire que
si vous proposez du travail pour ces
jours ci vous ne pourriez pas accepté et
là sinon j'aurais beaucoup aimé vous
n'aurez pas désolé j'ai pas désolé je
posais cette question pour être sûr de
pas trouver en vous un concurrent tenons
bouge toi que je peux vous annoncer la
grande nouvelle
allez
je vais travailler c'est vrai bravo
je vais être responsable de la publicité
de la société casino prend forme
à travers moi que va fabriquer cette
société casimir
alors
des cocottes en papier décor est donc
pour l'instant personne ne le sert comme
bientôt grâce à son génie tous les
habitants de nos enfants sont au courant
que fait qu'un signal est très en retard
mais ne vous en faites pas monsieur du
snob casimir n'a certainement pas changé
de chef de publicité tenez asseyez-vous
là
et il le fera certainement s'il vous
trouvez aussi abattu
responsable de publicité c'est quelqu'un
de gai
et
il faut que mon enthousiasme gens de
vivre donna toute l'envié d'acheter des
produits de la société cast
regarde
chers amis
admirez ma forme vous pensez sûrement
quand je reviens de vacances à la
montagne n'est pas du tout si je suis si
ghesquière eux c'est que chaque matin en
me réveillant je vois sur ma table de
nuit une cocotte en papier la société
kadimi bravo
merci je vous engage tous fini votre
contrat donc voilà je ne regretterai pas
de m'avoir engagé kazemi bassamois tous
les habitants de nos enfants pourront
tout à
avaler avant les a avalés à aa je crois
en effet que vous avez trouvé le mot
juste
casimir touring comme ça vos vieux ou
pourront rien c'est simplement une
petite phrase du contrat qu'il vient de
signer ils s'engagent à avaler avec le
sourire le produit à vendre devant
chaque habitant de l'île
les cocottes en papier
non non non pas du tout avant j'ai
justement changer d'avis je vais
désormais vendre du gloubiboulga
hockey